[Music]
good morning John it's Monday July 16th
okay I need to recreate this photograph
so first things first I need to shave
different Chin's very different Chin's
look better I can't find any eyeliner or
lipstick especially any lipstick that
color so I think I'm gonna have to go
out and try and find something though
I'm not entirely sure where one buys
lipstick I have good news
I found eyeliner and lipstick in
Catherine's little bag and hopefully she
won't mind me using them but she's not
here to ask but I don't want to wait
until she gets home to do this it's not
turn more colors there mm-hmm the same
color oh that is so strange how
difficult this is feel really weird
about this
[Music]
I know what you thinking you're looking
Hank that's not nearly dark enough my
goodness do I look funny we must now
continue to recreate this photograph now
for the final pose we're going to move
the camera so here goes nothing
so here I am in the basement it's dark
it feels kind of goth II don't really go
thick at all the gothy it's definitely a
flash when this picture was taken so I'm
not sure how I'm gonna recreate that
effect but we'll figure it out that way
my right hand is out success I think
that I should take some time to reflect
about what I've done today and how it
made me feel mostly it's strange how
weird it was to actually be doing the
lipstick thing because that was like
this is a girl thing I can't do the girl
thing I'm a boy then the eyeliner after
getting over the whole like poking
myself in the face thing was fun
I liked kind of again like doing that I
sang a little bit John I will see you
and you're extremely embarrassing
picture tomorrow
just dude ma makeup fair on the floor in
the living room hope that melody doesn't
come by cuz you'll see me doing my
makeup and should think I'm a pretty
weird guy I'm a pretty weird guy
my heart
ah huh huh huh huh